l'achat local à la cote c'est vrai pour
les légumes est de plus en plus pour les
fleurs résultat les fermes florales sont
en pleine croissance d'ailleurs la
formule de l'abonnement au panier de
légumes est désormais adapté aux paniers
de fleurs histoire de nourrir les yeux
et le coeur
vendredi midi à blainville dans les
laurentides
daphné vieira marché son bouquet de
fleurs qu'il fera plaisir à quelqu'un
qu'elle aime merci beaucoup moi et mes
frères et soeurs en est pris à un
abonnement pour notre mal à safaga
février et elles vont recevoir quelques
bouquets comme ça durant la saison donc
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui est venu le
chercher je valais emporté chez
schaeffler sont toutes réservées aux
abonnés elles ont été produites et
préparer dans une ferme florane situé
pas très loin d'ici à saint joseph du
lac
et des cultures qu'on veut qu'il y ait
des cultures qu'on réussit moins bien ça
dépend des années ça dépend du temps
louis mais ces leçons russe c'est là ils
sont super u si c'était vraiment moi ce
qui me fait vraiment tripé c'est de
produire des fleurs avant tout après
coup les bouquets que je forme que je
vends soit sur formules d'abonnement
soit en vente libre ça reste des
bouquets s'en est sans prétention c'est
vraiment et des bouquets que moi
j'aimerais recevoir mais clémence rivard
hiller est une fermière fleuriste elle
est à la fois productrice en
horticulture ornementale et créatrice
d'arrangements floraux j'aime produire
j'aime partir à partir d'une semence
puis créer quelque chose de beau qui est
vivant puis qui permet de propager le
bonheur ça ça me remplit de joie j'aime
vraiment
les plantes fleuries son chant puis sont
arrangés en bouquet est distribué aux
abonnés ou encore vendu à des grossistes
pour les fleuristes ou décorateurs
d'événements
la popularité de la culture à petite
échelle de fleurs coupées explose auprès
du public depuis quelques années un peu
partout dans les circuits de kiosque et
légumes on trouve des fleurs à vendre
rapprocher les gens de la saisonnalité
aussi c'est important je pense des fois
je trouve qu'on est déconnecté de
qu'est-ce que c'est une saison qui
du lieu dans lequel on vit on habite à
quoi se serait approprié un peu la
nature chez soi
[Musique]
en 2021 selon le ministère de
l'agriculture
il y avait une cinquantaine de fermes de
fleurs coupées celles qui pratiquent la
vente directe couvrent moins d'un
hectare et n'ont que quelques années
d'existence elles appartiennent presque
toutes à des femmes clef dans ses
lancers en 2018
à 26 ans je me suis découvert une forte
phase passion pour les fleurs je
trouvais ça tombe au don intéressant et
je savais pas qu'on pouvait cultiver des
fleurs puis gtc me lancer
les faire ou on récolte des fleurs de
cette manière ne sont pas mécanisée et
repose sur des employés c'est une
production qui se rapproche de
l'agriculture maraîchère de type
biologique intensifs la plantation se
fait manuellement l'installation des
étoiles de culture se fait manuellement
la récolte se fait manuellement le
désherbage se fait manuellement la façon
qu'ont fait la culture elle est
tellement de condenser qui aurait aucun
équipement mécanisé qui serait capable
de vraiment y accéder correctement
et en même temps mais c'est c'est de
l'amour cordes ont leur on leur fait
attention à nos fleurs
en 2020 et 2021 s'approvisionner on se
ment ça a été difficile un enjeu car
pour réussir de beaux arrangements les
variétés récoltées doivent être
nombreuses
les fleurs kippen ch qui accompagne qui
donne l'effet vaporub comme ceux ci nous
glace aux amabilités ouais en grèce a
chinese farguettes minutes c'est son
petit nom fait quelque chose qui est
très apprécié des abeilles
la culture des fleurs est possible même
dans des régions plus froides ça
nécessite un climat qui est constante je
dirais quelque chose qui est difficile à
accomplir dans nos jours des excès de
chaleur peuvent être vraiment fatale
pour certaines cultures comme le pois de
senteur qui déteste avoir trop chaud
mais qui sont si bons qu'ils ont
vraiment une fleur plaisir
souvent s'est associé à beaucoup de
souvenirs pour des gens parce que c'est
une fleur qui très très ancienne
puis pour nous c'est vraiment le fait
poussé par plaisir on envoie un petit
peur mais c'est beaucoup pour
pour nous mêmes la production en champs
de fleurs coupées est une culture
délicate il y à des pertes dans les
semis à la plantation en chant à la
récolte
le client qui s'abonnent aux fleurs
locales se contente de la fleur de
saison et accepte même les trash de
petites morsures d'insectes
certains dommages sont vraiment minard
et esthétique on le fait de simplement
éduquer notre clientèle à savoir que ce
n'est pas la fleur elle est toujours
aussi viable est toujours aussi belle
c'est vraiment jusqu'à eu le passage
mais c'est parce que les élections
partout autour de nous
et comme les voyons vous en trouvez
aujourd'hui clémence et ses employés
préparent les bouquets pour les clients
abonnés et une cinquantaine d'autres
pour la vente libre
en 2021 la ferme à 240 abonnés
les fleurs locales bénéficient de la
même vague d'amour que les paniers de
légumes des fermiers de famille qui
l'ont connu en 2021 une hausse au québec
de près de 50 % des abonnements on a vu
qu'il y avait comme un engouement donc
on a ouvert ce plus large ça nous
permettait d'avoir un marché qui étaient
plus fiables étant donné que c'est nous
mêmes qui démarre trop produits qu'elle
valorise
ya certaines fleurs qui ont besoin
d'être coupée à maturité tandis que
d'autres fleurs qui ont besoin qu'on
récolte vraiment je dirais à 30 ou 50 %
d'ouverture puis on continue à se
développer chez le client dans leurs
bases
le secret c'est d'abord un vent ce prof
c'est de changer son nom régulièrement
quand j'étais régulièrement c'est au
jour ou deux jours c'est de recouper ses
tiges puis aussi de s'approprier son
bouquet les six ont toutes une durée de
vie différente si mettons au mx 3 à 4
cultivant dans un bouquet il veut pas
des perrés au même rythme donc lorsque
une tige qui commence à avoir la mine
basse vaut mieux langue béton bouquet
sinon il a tendance à contaminer les
autres puis à faire dépérir le reste ça
gagne plutôt et l'abonné peut ainsi
fleurir sa maison huit ou dix jours en
attendant le prochain bouquet de la
ferme
on élimine des tiges de ses défauts
parce qu'ils sont trop
sont trop ouverte à ce moment là mais ça
s'en va au plafond toutes ces fleurs h
et seront écoulés plus tard une manière
de valoriser les invendus
les fermes florin de proximité sont
apparus aux états unis vers 2000 en
opposition aux lots de fleurs importées
d'amérique du sud et d'afrique tout
uniforme est parfaite les flancs chang
sont tous différents villon pas toutes
la même taille ont peut-être le même
volume ayons pour tout les mêmes
tonalités ils sont toutes belles parties
sont différentes pour certains les
fleurs peuvent être bien de luxe mais
clément souhaiterait que ses fleurs soit
accessible car ils font du bien
je pense que ça fait bien au montage
pense que ça fait bien à son chez soi
il donne tout en ce moment ils sont en
train de se mettre le plus belle
possible dans le but d'être polliniser
puis de revivre l'année suivante
[Musique]